le parquet financier il a été créé à
tort voir et je ne me prononcerai pas
sur cette question
il a été créé pour traiter des affaires
particulièrement complexe et des
affaires qui avaient un champ
d'application sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
est ce que le fait de savoir si m fillon
a effectivement rempli ses fonctions
d'assistant parlementaire est un
problème financier d'une particulière
gravité ou d'une particulière difficulté
pardon est ce que le fait de savoir si
nicolas sarkozy ou pas à chercher à
s'informer sur mes affaires qu'il
concernait ou si on lui a demandé
d'intervenir auprès du ministre d'état
de monaco pour favoriser un l'un de ses
amis est ce que ce sont des affaires
d'une particulière gravité est ce que on
a on peut saisir les agendas du un
président un ancien président de la
république
probablement en violation de
dispositions de la constitution
est-ce qu'on peut écouter les
conversations entre un ancien président
de la république et l'un de ses avocats
on voit bien qu'il y a là des moyens
extraordinaires et ses moyens
extraordinaires ça rejoint probablement
un autre aspect c est ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les priorités aujourd'hui
finalement la priorité c'est
probablement plus les délits de droit
commun ce sont les délits commis par les
hommes politiques et je dis bien non pas
les seulement les délits financiers on
l'a vu dans leur sphère strauss kahn
c'est pas un délit financier mais il y a
un certain nombre de priorités et ce qui
est grave c'est que ces priorités elles
sont légitimes ou pas mais ses priorités
elles sont fixées par les juges
eux-mêmes
les juges ont des héros on vient de le
dire
les juges ont des modèles les juges ont
des combats et le problème c'est qu'il
n'appartient pas au juge d'avoir des
combats bon ou mauvais il appartient au
juge simplement de traiter
les justiciables de la même manière
[Musique]